رغم بلوغه المئه عام لا زال الثعلب العجوز
محطه انظار العالم لما يمتلكهم من فهم
عميق للاحداث حول العالم هنري كاسنجر
الحكيم كما يلقبه مؤيدوه ومجرم الحرب كما
يرغب البعض بتسميته عبر في احتفال عيده
المئه عن رايه فيما يحدث حول العالم كسنجر
لا يرى فرقا بين بايدن وترامب فيما يتعلق
بالسياسه حول الصين التي راها قوه وخصما
محتملا خطيرا لبلاده رغم هذه الرؤيه الا
ان كسنجر دعا للحوار مع الصين وايضا دعا
للابتعاد عن الخصومه الطائشه من اجل
مواجهه هذا الخطر كسنجر حذر من ان صراعا
بين القوتين سيدمر الحضاره البشريه وبينما
اكد كسنجر دعمه لموقف بلاده المؤيد لكيف
بالملف الروسي الاوكراني حذر من خساره
روسيا هذه الحرب كسنجر شدد على ضروره
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار حجمها وطبيعته وتاريخ
رو التي باتت اليوم تشعر بانها تعامل
بدونيه مع تصاعد العداء الاوروبي والغربي
ضدها دببه السياسه الامريكيه شدد على ان
خساره سيفاستوبول في شبه جزيره القرم
ستكون بمثابه عاصفه تجعل تماسك الدوله في
خطر ملمحا الى انها لم تكن دائما اوكرانيه
عبر التاريخ
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات